hello this blows that is okay is you  good cuz I want to know I'm talking to  you about my fertility journey I'm one  of those people that's willing to try  anything at this point to have kids  I'm Shauna I am glozell surrogate you  might see a little white flash which is  the embryo is going in that is it I say  this is writing an essay a boy it's a  little hard to see but see that little  white like almost like a grain of rice  yes that's your baby pictures looks just  like me  yeah I'm really thinking as a boy I  actually went to a psychic he said I  feel a very strong feminine energy I am  dying to know the gender and I have a  few little tests to figure out am i  pregnant with a boy I'm here with Liz's  mom Gloria she's come from Florida to go  sell some good news well you have to  beat it out  you